went through Metapause and began having hot flashes a year ago.
I had COVID approximately one month ago,
and the hot flashes have worsened
along with the teeth, brain fog,
decreased sense of taste and smell.
Maybe some of you can share your regimen regarding
how you rebuild your system post COVID,
but also your regimen during Metapause.
So having symptoms of hot flashes during Metapause,
let's tackle that first.
So the reason why I partied as hot flashes during Metapause,
and some people go through Metapause,
it don't have any Metapausal symptoms.
Why is that?
Because Metapause is your ovary starting to shut down.
Your ovaries are your main source of production
for a progesterone and estrogen.
However, if you have really healthy adrenal glands,
your adrenal glands will semi-makeup
for the loss of estrogen progesterone
so that you can go through Metapause
without having symptoms.
So a person that has hot flashes,
a person that has to the degree that they have symptoms
during Metapause really is a picture of the degree
of their ill health of their adrenal glands.
Because Metapause naturally is going to be
a decreased function of your ovaries.
Again, if you have really healthy adrenal glands,
those are the people that sail through Metapause
and say, I went through Metapause,
great a city of the world,
I don't have to deal with my multicycle anymore,
never had any symptoms and other women are like,
why do I have all these symptoms?
And what's wrong with me?
Well, what you'd be deployed to is what makes up
for that loss of estrogen progesterone
at least to smooth that out to a gradual point
because even people post Metapause
will still have estrogen progesterone.
Where is that coming from?
Even people that have had a hysterectomy
still have estrogen progesterone.
Where is that coming from?
It's coming from the adrenal glands.
So the adrenal glands never will make a save amount
as the ovaries are currently making pre-metapausal,
but they'll make enough to keep you from having these symptoms.
And the symptoms are these fluctuations in estrogen.
That's what causes the symptoms.
And the adrenal glands should keep you healthy
adrenal glands should keep you from these fluctuations.
Why it is a person going through Metapause,
having high flashes and they got worse
and a whole bunch of other symptoms got worse
when they had COVID.
Well, you could say when they had an infection,
when they had a strep,
when they had a high degree of stress,
when they went through a divorce,
when anything that's going to put more stress
on your adrenal glands is going to take away
from the adrenal glands' ability to produce estrogen
and progesterone for you to smooth your way through Metapause.
So when you're having Metapause symptoms,
it's really a function of your adrenal glands.
So supporting adrenal glands should be your first thought.
How do you support the adrenal glands?
How could you, first of all, take a step back?
How could you measure adrenal gland function?
There is a test called,
it's a functional medicine test called
an adrenal stress test.
It measures cortisol through your cycle of a day.
So you wanna do this test on a normal day,
not on a heavy stress day,
a day that you're under,
you're almost burdened mentally,
but on a day that's gonna be fairly normal.
Maybe you'd say, well, that's every day of my heavy burden day.
Well, that may be true.
But you wanna do it on a fairly normal day
and the test will give you instructions.
It is, you are either doing a salivary,
usually it's a salivary sample
at four different times during the day.
And you're marking it down,
you're writing another test to what this is at 8 a.m.
This is at midnight.
This is at, you know,
the new to this is at three o'clock.
I think those are the typical times
for a salivary adrenal stress test.
And you should see the cortisol levels.
So that's measuring cortisol levels.
There's other tests that you could also get at the HEA level.
Now, I'd recommend somebody going through these symptoms,
having metapausal issues,
is to do the Dutch test.
That's a dried urine hormone test for your hormones.
And then it also is testing,
that's the Dutch plus, I think.
It's also testing the salivary cortisol levels.
Because then you'll get a picture of your adrenal function
and you'll get a picture of your other hormones, the D-A-T-A,
which is another hormone released by the adrenal glands,
which is a precursor to some progesterone
and some of your endrogens.
And you'll get a measurement of your estrogen's progesterone,
all of the metabolites thereof, and your endrogens.
So it gives you a good picture of your hormone levels
and your cortisol level.
So it gives you a good picture of your adrenals
and your omurries,
which you can then give, you can discern
the help of your tuteric gland,
which is the gland that stimulates all these things.
So, when a person is, again, going through metapause,
their lack of progesterone estrogen is made up
by the health of their adrenal glands.
If that is compromised, they're gonna have metapausal symptoms.
And then if they have an increased adrenal stress
from a virus or a bacterial infection,
or a stressful event,
or anything else that can compromise the adrenal glands,
you're gonna have a worsening of those symptoms.
So, addressing the health of the adrenal glands
through testing it would be one thing,
and then from nutritional addressing the adrenal glands
would be by taking supplements
wise, would be taking the daptogens.
Not a big fan of taking DHEA.
Typically, I would recommend DHEA,
because it is a hormone, whenever you take a hormone,
you're gonna have a negative feedback loop
for the hormone production.
So, if you take DHEA, you're basically telling
your adrenal glands that there's plenty of it,
so it's basically shutting down the adrenals more.
So, I typically only recommend DHEA
for a very short period of time,
and it's only when a person is an absolute,
complete, adrenal exhaustive fatigue.
I'd rather give adeptogens,
and supporting the adrenal gland functions
through herbal adeptogens,
and building up the adrenals through adrenal tissue,
supplements, I think that's a better way to go.
Hopefully that answers your question.